Adam starts off this hour in Tulsa
Oklahoma hi Adam welcome to the Dave
Ramsey show David's an honor to get
stuff to you you too
what's up so my wife and I are 100% debt
free and we are saving up for our
celebratory car we're just wondering
your thoughts on courtesy vehicles the
loners that dealerships give out while
you're getting your oil change then they
sell with a couple thousand miles on
them don't know anything about them
other than I've seen them on the road I
guess like you have I would assume
they've had a lot of miles put on them
in a short period of time city driving
right yeah they usually sell about a
year olds about five or six thousand
miles on them and they're usually about
five thousand or seven thousand dollars
cheaper than a new one okay I guess if
you can find one that's exactly what you
want and in good shape I don't have a
problem with that and of course we don't
buy brand new cars around here unless
you've got a million dollar net worth or
great right so yeah you'll be buying a
used car obviously
well I'm not you're talking about
spending on this car okay and your
household income is what about 85
okay so the other car is worth 5,000 I
have got a company vehicle so you don't
have another car okay no it's a one-car
family you're gonna spend 40 grand on a
car making 80
alright and I assume you have the cash
yeah okay okay and you have your
emergency fund obviously yeah okay is
your home paid off okay I misunderstood
I thought you said your baby step 4
okay cool yeah I got no issue with this
yeah pay cash for it and whatever you
want to do hi I don't have any
background earning knowledge on that
particular method of buying a car I mean
it's kind of buying a demo I guess is in
a sense what it is but you know if you
it does fit in
guidelines that we give you pay cash and
your total of your vehicles is less than
half your annual income and that's right
where we tell you to be and if you're
not a millionaire we don't buy brand-new
cars so being here after if you want to
spend that much on a car and it goes
down in value you can afford to take the
hit but prior to that you can't so that
that's the the whole thing so hey thanks
for calling guys here's the deal here's
the thing to think about okay I love
cars I get a bunch of cars
I like okay I'm just a classic boy I
like cars
okay I mean when I was seven years old
or five years old in the backseat I
would turn a pencil eraser into a carbon
right I mean I'm that guy right
and so I'm with you if you want a nice
car you like nice cars you know I got
sent me a link buddy mine sent me a link
this morning the new Mustang that's 750
horsepower that's just rocketship that's
so fun I like cars I'm okay with you
having a car the thing is you just have
to use some common dadgum sense about
vehicles because 99.9% of them go down
in value and the other point one percent
of classic cars that you're buying and
you know something about buying them in
an investment situation but 99 percent
things with wheels on them and motors in
them go down in value the typical new
car will lose 60 to 70 percent of its
value in the first four years that's a
thirty two thousand dollar car that
becomes worth about ten thousand and
four years so every four years you're
taking $22,000 and burning it with a
cigarette lighter flames a bonfire gone
twenty two thousand dollars if you're
doing that and you don't make really a
lot of money and you don't have any
money you are guaranteeing that you're
not gonna be wealthy when you buy
expensive things that go down in value
duh it's going to cause you to have
trouble building wealth or probably keep
you from building
well and so we ever driven down through
a neighborhood where the two cars
sitting in front of the house are almost
as expensive as the house and the whole
freaking street is that way that means
that the average person living on that
streets 32 years old that's what that
means and you go down through there and
these are people more concerned about
what they drive and they've you know got
to fleece cars sitting there they got
you know dadgum bass boat in the
driveway and it was $32,000 to you know
and had to have a bigger motor those
bass were outrunning me
and so you upgrade in that puppy it's
just you know we all like our toys but
your toys are destroying your life so
it's okay for her for him he's in a good
place to buy a car he's in a great place
to buy a car and so buy that car there's
no problem with that but most people you
just have to stop and think you can't
you know you can't turn $32,000 in to 10
grand very often and have any money you
got to really make a lot of money to do
that you got to have a lot of money to
do that now you know if you've got some
money because you've sacrificed you can
afford to take some of those hits if you
want to spend it on a car that's fine
and I do I've got some nice cars and
they go down in value just like I'm
talking about but it's a very very very
small percentage of my income and a very
very very small percentage of my net
worth that's going the wrong direction
down and so as long as it's a small
percentage I can enjoy my boats and my
cars and my truck and different things
right they got motors in them but
otherwise I mean if you guys if your
household income of 100 grand and you
got $70,000 a rolling stock sitting in
front of your house you're just straight
up mathematically an idiot I mean you're
just stupid because it's killing you
these things go down in value
like a rock that's where Chevy got that
like a rock Fords know better it's found
on the road depreciated it's all going
down in value
so don't spend your money and don't for
God's sakes don't go into debt and put
large portions of your financial
situation large portions of your income
large portions of your net worth and
things that are going down in value and
then scratch your head and wonder why
you're broke that's why the largest
thing most people buy that goes down in
value is a car it's that simple and the
largest thing most people buy is a house
it goes up in value the largest thing
most people buy that goes down in value
is a car and it's a big honking item so
don't let your cars drive you drive your
cars
own your cars don't let them on you and
then you feel drive like no one else
don't care what's everybody thinks later
you can drive like no one else and don't
care what anybody thinks
it becomes a pattern of your life pay a
price to win
[Music]